Prof: Okay we're going
to talk about several different
things today,
several different texts,
because we're coming up to the
end of the semester.
I often conclude with two
different lectures that talk
about the rise of
institutionalism and
institutionalization of the
church,
but I've decided this year to
combine them into one.
That's why your reading list,
your reading for today,
had some canonical material,
the letters of Ignatius,
you're also asked to read the
Didache,
another non-canonical early
Christian writing because I want
to pull different themes
together.
So next time,
the last class of the course,
the last lecture,
I want to then address the
kinds of big questions you might
have been having all semester,
which can be something like,
how did this little bitty group
of people following this unknown
Jew in Syrian Palestine in the
first century become this huge
world religion?
What's the continuity,
if any, because I've been
stressing all--
in the whole semester the
differences between contemporary
notions about Christianity,
what Christianity is,
what is orthodox Christianity
for people in our day and age,
what people assume Christianity
is all about.
I've been talking about how
that's very different from the
canonical Christianity that we
see in the New Testament,
and it's even more different
from some of the non-canonical
Christianity that we've seen in
things like the Acts of Paul
and Thecla.
Next time I will talk about the
bigger issue of the growth of
Christianity from this fledgling
little movement and a few house
churches scattered around in
Greek cities in the Eastern
Mediterranean.
I'll also talk next time a
little about what is post-modern
interpretation of scripture.
I did talk a bit about the
theological interpretation of
scripture and how that's
different from the historical
critical interpretation of
scripture that you're learning
in this semester.
If you really want to get into
theological interpretation of
scripture in an academic
environment you need to do that
through something like the
Divinity School or in a seminary
because that's,
of course, where they're
supposed to be teaching people
how to interpret this text for
contemporary Christians.
That's not what we're going to
talk about in this course most
of the time.
I have hinted at that,
but there's also a way of
approaching scripture that might
be considered not the canonical
traditional way of theological
interpretation and also not the
modernist way of modern
historical criticism,
and that's what we might call
post-modern approaches to the
text,
and even to the text as
scripture itself.
Next time I'll address some of
those bigger issues about the
New Testament that I've kind of
put on the side for the whole
semester.
Today we're taking a first step
toward that because I'm going to
look at some canonical material
in this lecture,
but I'm also going to look at
the letters of Ignatius and the
Didache to show you how
the church started becoming
institutionalized in ways that
look more familiar to us after
the period of the New Testament
composition.
How do you create and maintain
unity in a social movement?
That's what early Christian
leaders had to face pretty
quickly.
We've already seen that in
Paul's letters,
right?
In 1 Corinthians shows a church
that is at odds with itself.
People disagreeing about what
the basic nature of the Gospel
is,
and Paul writes 1 Corinthians
in order,
the whole theme of 1
Corinthians is,
you are the united body of
Christ now start acting like it.
And so Paul's trying to get a
fractured church to see so it's
united.
There are different ways you
can see this being done in early
Christianity.
Paul, of course,
didn't have church structures
to appeal to.
Paul couldn't say something
like, if you have a question go
to your bishop.
He also couldn't say,
look at the New Testament,
he was writing it at the
time.
There wasn't anything like that
to look at.
Paul exercised his own
charismatic authority.
By that, we mean that in the
sort of Weberian sociological
sense of an authority that
doesn't derive from an office,
from any kind of official
office that Paul had,
but it derives from simply his
force of character.
When someone has a leadership
position that derives more from
their personality,
their force of character,
their ideas than it does from
an official office then that's
charismatic authority as opposed
to an official kind of
institutional authority.
That's what Paul had to deal
with.
That's what all the earliest
leaders of these little house
churches had to deal with.
They had to push their own
ideas of what the church meant,
of what the body of Christ
meant, of what was proper
ethics,
of what proper interpretation
of scripture,
and they had to do it on the
strength of their own character
and their force of personality.
That was one way that people
tried to create unity in this
early fledgling movement.
Gradually, of course,
you have other ways of
developing.
Another way of developing unity
that we see around this time is
hierarchical leadership.
You have officers,
you have people who are either
elected or appointed as
officers, and they control unity
and enforce unity from the top
down.
And you can see this,
therefore, in modern
Christianity,
modern religious movements.
The Roman Catholic Church has
bishops, and cardinals,
and the Pope.
And everybody who knows
anything about Roman Catholicism
knows that what the Pope and the
cardinals say goes,
or it's supposed too.
American Roman Catholics and a
lot of northern western European
Catholics sometimes don't go
along with The Vatican on many
things,
but the structure of the Roman
Catholic Church is intended to
help maintain unity by the means
of an official hierarchical
leadership structure.
You also have different
Protestant ways to do this which
are constitutional kinds of
systems.
When say, the Presbyterians,
have debates about whether to
ordain homosexuals,
whether to allow gay marriages,
the ordination of women,
which was the debate that
really rocked the Presbyterian
church and many other churches
back in the 1970s,
most of them got over that by
now;
now the thing that's rocking
them is sexuality.
When they had disagreements
they would go to the general
convention,
which occurs every year,
and you have people elected out
of different local churches and
parishes,
and presbyteries,
they call them the Presbyterian
Church,
and those people who are
themselves basically elected
from their local churches and
their local presbyteries are
representatives to the general
convention.
It looks very much like
American politics.
It's not much of an accident.
The American Constitution to
some extent,
is based on what was a more
Presbyterian Protestant kind of
church polity,
of having different houses of
representatives and this sort of
thing.
So American denominations,
Protestant denominations,
which were growing up at the
same time,
as different Protestant
movements were growing up,
and at the same time as
American constitutionalism was
growing up,
all influenced each other.
That's another way to maintain
unity that Protestant churches
tend to use.
Then you have other churches in
America that are very free
churches.
I grew up in a denomination
that didn't even call itself a
denomination because it
considered itself simply the
Church,
called the Church of Christ,
and the Churches of Christ
don't have any national offices,
no place you can go anywhere in
the world like there are for
most other denominations that
have a national office with
officers and set rules and
decide on hymn books and decide
on Sunday school materials.
There's nothing like that
anywhere in the world.
These churches are all
completely autonomous and
individual to themselves.
They appoint their own
officers, they decide what is
doctrine and what is not
doctrine,
they hire and fire their own
ministers,
and not even the ministers of
these churches are the highest
authorities.
They basically preach and
teach, but they're not the ones
who actually run the churches,
so each individual
church--there are lots of
churches like that in the United
States.
There are a lot of Baptist
churches that aren't even part
of the Southern Baptist
Convention.
There are lots of free churches
and some of them would even have
"free"
as part of their name.
Of course in America this is
not at all unusual.
Anybody can rent out a
storefront and start their own
church, and many people have
done so.
These kinds of churches,
it's remarkable that the
denomination I grew up in,
although there's no
meta-congregational organization
that runs this,
it's amazing how much alike
they are.
When I was a kid I would travel
to Alabama, or to Maryland,
or to St.
Louis, Missouri,
and you would go to a Church of
Christ,
as long as it said it on its
sign and it was one of the same
kinds we went to,
and the services would be the
same,
They sing the same songs,
they have the same doctrine.
It's almost like somebody wrote
it all out and said,
this is what you'll do on
Sunday morning.
The amazing thing was nobody
had written it all out.
It was just done by the sheer
nature of these churches of
being very close knit and sort
of ruling each other by
threatening to dis-fellowship
you if you didn't do like
everybody else did.
There was a great amount of
cohesiveness.
In fact, I remember being
astounded when I was twenty
years old,
and I was in a rock band at my
college,
and we did a two-month tour for
the USO playing on military
bases all over--
in Japan, Taiwan,
Okinawa, Hawaii,
the South Pacific,
different places,
the Philippines.
And we would actually--because
the college I went to was a
Church of Christ College we
would often visit a Church of
Christ in Tokyo or wherever we
were in Asia.
It was amazing.
You would go in,
and although everything was in
Japanese, it was exactly like it
was back in Texas.
There was no organization
forcing this.
It was just the cohesiveness of
the socialization of these
different groups.
What we're going to see today
is the move in early
Christianity,
the very beginnings of the move
from this freewheeling,
charismatic,
structureless kind of
organization structure and
authority practice that we see
in Paul's letters and in other
documents we've looked at so
far,
and we're going to see a move
towards more
institutionalization.
It's not going to be the
Catholic Church yet,
it's not going to be what
becomes Christianity in the
fourth and fifth centuries,
when it does become much more
highly organized.
But we're going to start seeing
that move.
We see the move a little bit
already in the letter of Jude,
so open your Bibles and look
with me at Jude.
Jude claims to be the brother
of James,
and scholars think most of the
time what he's trying to do is
claim that he's the brother of
James,
who was the head of the
Jerusalem Church,
that is, James the brother of
Jesus.
Jude, by that figuring,
would also make himself the
brother of Jesus.
Mark 6:3 or Matthew 13:55 links
these guys together.
What most scholars think is
that this pseudonymous,
you won't be surprised now to
know that we don't think the
brother of Jesus or the brother
of James actually wrote this
text.
What we know of Judas,
who would have been and of
course as I think I've explained
already,
"Jude"
is simply the Anglicization of
the Greek name Judas,
which is simply a Greek version
of the Hebrew name Judah,
so they all refer basically to
the same name.
Jude, or Judas,
or Judah was--if he was a
brother of Jesus as the Gospels
seem to imply,
then he was an illiterate
fisherman,
and we don't think someone with
his background,
with his lack of education
would have been able to write
this letter.
So that's the reason we
basically assign it to
pseudonymity.
He's dealing with some
divisions;
I'm not going to go through the
letter very much because I want
to move ahead to some of these
other documents.
There are signs,
like I talked about with 1 and
2 Peter last time,
that this is a post-apostolic
letter.
One of those is verse 3:
Beloved while eagerly preparing
to write you about the salvation
we share,
I find it necessary to write
and to appeal to you to contend
for the faith that was once for
all entrusted to the saints.
This faith is this thing that
was delivered to the saints at
one time.
He also talks in verse 17 about
the Apostles,
But you, beloved,
must remember the predictions
of the apostles of our Lord
Jesus;
for they said to you,
"In the last time there
will be scoffers indulging their
own ungodly lust."
So he sees himself living in
the last times,
but he didn't see the apostles
living in the last times.
Even though Peter,
and James, and John saw
themselves as living in the last
times,
he's living far enough after
them so that he could put them
in a prior time,
a sort of apostolic stage of
the church,
and now he's writing in the
last times.
So this is a post-apostolic
letter.
But it's also pre-canonical,
as I said last time talking
about 2 Peter.
Remember I talked about how 2
Peter uses this letter of Jude
as a model for his own letter,
and he quotes stuff out of out,
takes stuff out of it.
One of the things,
though, 2 Peter did was,
he took out the stuff that he
found in Jude that was not
canonical,
that he didn't believe was part
of the real Bible.
But Jude has it in there.
In verse 9, "But when the
archangel Michael contended with
the devil and disputed about the
body of Moses,"
and he goes on says what
happened.
Well, why does this happen?
Is this in your Bible?
Nope, it's not in your Bible.
Michael never disputed about
what to do with the body of
Moses after Moses died according
to our Bible.
It is in a Jewish document we
call the Assumption of
Moses.
He's citing a Jewish document
that's not in the Bible that we
use, and it may be that that's
why the 2 Peter took that
reference out.
He didn't want the
Assumption of Moses being
cited in this text.
He also, as I said last time,
he cites some Enoch material in
verses 14 and 15.
It was also about these that
Enoch in the seventh generation
from Adam prophesied saying,
"See the Lord is coming
with ten thousands of his Holy
ones."
What we have now,
literature, under the name of
Enoch,
which was written probably
written over a period of a few
centuries,
was an accumulation of several
different documents,
but it started being written in
the third century BCE and then
was added onto in the centuries
after that.
So he cites materials from the
Assumption of Moses and
Enoch,
which demonstrates that he's
still living in a time when
what's considered scripture by
these early followers of Jesus
is still in a state of flux,
so he's not writing in a time
where the Canon,
even the Jewish Canon,
the Hebrew Bible Canon,
has been set yet.
He's also writing in a time
when some of the Eucharistic
practices may also be not like
they were later.
Look at verse 12,
"These are blemishes on
your love feast [your agapes]
whilst they feast without fear,
feeding themselves,"
and he goes on and condemns the
people.
These agapes probably refer to
the taking of the Communion,
The Lord's Supper,
but in the context of a bigger
meal as we've seen was the case
also in Corinth.
In 1 Corinthians 11,
Paul talks about them coming
together and having the meal,
and as part of that meal they
would have the wine and the
bread of the Lord's Supper.
So Jude represents an in
between time in early
Christianity that's
post-apostolic,
so it's not of the apostolic
period as Paul's letters are,
Paul's authentic letters,
but it's also not quite to the
firm ecclesiastical institutions
that now for the rest of today
and next time I'll talk about
become formed.
You don't have here,
at this point yet,
bishops, set creeds,
set liturgies,
and set scripture.
All of those things will later
be used to settle disputes.
What did I say?
Bishops, creeds,
liturgy, and scripture.
Those are four things that come
to be used as,
you might call them,
technologies of unity,
technologies of control in
bringing unity out of this wild
diversity of early Christianity
that we've been making a theme
of this course all along the
way.
Then the next thing we want to
talk about is the letters of
Ignatius,
because he then represents
another stage in this process,
and especially the use of the
office of the bishop itself.
First, you notice how much
Ignatius makes himself out to be
this great martyr.
Part of his authority derives
simply from the fact that he's
been arrested and he's being
taken from Antioch,
where he was bishop,
to Rome to stand trial and then
to be killed.
Along the way,
he writes these letters when
he's going through Asia Minor,
to different cities in Asia
Minor, sort of like the author
of Revelation had done.
Notice what he does:
he plays on the idea that he's
going to die and he makes so
much out of it that it becomes
pretty much gross.
Look, for example,
at the Letter to the
Romans if you can find it in
your packet.
I need to have a Bible song for
Ignatius' letters so we'll know
where to find them.
It's toward the last one.
The Letter to the Romans
from Ignatius.
Look at chapter 4:
For my part I am writing to all
the churches and assuring them
that I am truly in earnest about
dying for God,
if only you yourselves put no
obstacles in my way.
So he's telling the Romans,
when I'm getting tried and put
before the beast,
don't you try to intervene and
save me,
don't try to save me,
he's saying.
I must implore you to do me no
such untimely kindness.
Pray, leave me to be a meal for
the beasts, for it is they who
can provide my way to God.
I am his wheat,
ground fine by the lions'
teeth, to be made purest bread
for Christ.
Better still,
incite the creatures to become
a sepulcher for me.[He wants the
lions' bodies to be his tomb.]
Let them not leave the smallest
scrap of my flesh so that I need
not be a burden to anyone after
I fall asleep.
[I'll just sleep here in the
dark don't worry about me.]
When there is no trace of my
body left for the world to see,
then I shall truly be Jesus
Christ's disciple.
So intercede with him,
that is with God,
for me that by their
instrumentality [that is the
instruments of the lions]
I may be made a sacrifice to
God.
However, I am not issuing
orders to you as though I were a
Peter or a Paul [a little bit of
modesty here]
they were apostles.
I am just a condemned criminal.
They were free men.
I am still a slave.
Though if I suffer Jesus Christ
will give me liberty and in him
I shall rise again as a free
man.
For the present,
these chains are schooling me
to have done with earthly
desires.
Look at the next chapter,
chapter 5 and about halfway
down.
I don't have page numbers here.
"How I look forward,"
this becomes almost morbid.
Modern people reading Ignatius'
letters, and he looks like he's
morbid in his craving for
martyrdom.
That's how odd it looks to us
modern people.
How I look forward to the real
lions that have been got ready
for me!
All I pray is that I might find
them swift.
I am going to make overtures to
them,
so that unlike some other
wretches,
whom they have been too
spiritless to touch,
they may devour me with all
speed.
And if they are still reluctant
I shall use force to them.
[He's going to pull the lion's
teeth right toward his chest.]
You must forgive me but I do
know what is best for myself.
This is the first stage of my
discipleship,
and no power,
visible or invisible,
must grudge me my coming to
Jesus Christ.
Fire, crosses,
beast fighting,
hacking,
and quartering,
splintering of bone and
mangling of limb,
even the pulverizing of my
entire body,
let every horrid and diabolical
torment come upon me,
provided only that I can win my
way to Jesus Christ.
This is martyrology stuff,
folks.
This is the beginning of the
entire cult of the martyrs in
Christianity that becomes so
important in early Christianity
and then for hundreds of years.
Now Paul had also talked about
chains, his chains being
something that was good.
He gloried in his chains and
being in prison.
Ignatius takes this from Paul
and just runs with it even more.
In Ephesians,
the eleventh chapter of
Ephesians,
the letter not of Paul to the
Ephesians but the letter of
Ignatius to the Ephesians,
he talks about his chains as
pearls.
In the first chapter of this
letter of Ignatius to the
Romans, he talks about the
chains of Jesus.
Then also, I mentioned that he
sees himself,
in his martyrdom,
as getting closer to Jesus,
and in this he's becoming
himself--he calls himself in the
first part of this and the
second chapter of the letter to
the Romans,
the logos theou.
What do we know that means?
We've seen this logos
stuff before,
right?
Transliterated,
remember what logos
means?
The "word,"
correct, theou,
anybody know?
"Of God":
Ignatius himself is the
word of God.
This is what the Gospel of John
called Jesus;
Jesus was the Word of God.
Ignatius can even claim,
for himself,
the status that he,
especially to his martyrdom is
the Word of God.
Where does he get all this?
Well this is this developing
martryology kind of ideology in
literature.
The idea was,
in most of early Christianity,
if you're good Christian
people, when you die you won't
immediately go to heaven.
It's not like popular thinking
about Christian doctrine.
True Christian doctrine doesn't
say that you immediately go to
heaven.
necessarily.
It says that you may be sleep
or do something,
but you have to wait for the
resurrection of the body.
That's why you confess things
like in the Nicene Creed,
if you confess the resurrection
of the body or the resurrection
of the flesh.
That's because,
according to Christian
doctrine,
that's the true afterlife
experience,
not just the immortal soul
living forever,
but the resurrection of your
body, it's a newly made body.
But what happens before the
resurrection?
Because we all know that comes
at the end of time.
Well, most Christians believed
you slept somewhere,
or maybe your soul,
your spirit,
would go to some kind halfway
house.
This develops into the notion
of purgatory or some kind of
Hades-type place,
a place where you would either
sleep or your soul will go
someplace else,
and you'd wait for the
resurrection.
Well, according to developing
Christian ideas,
martyrs didn't have to wait for
the resurrection.
Once they were martyred,
as a reward for their
martyrdom, their spirit goes
straight to heaven to be with
Jesus immediately.
You bypass some bad waiting
room type experience if you're
martyred.
This became even so important
that people who were condemned
to be martyred but then weren't
actually killed,
for whatever reason,
sometimes people would be
condemned,
and maybe the beasts weren't
hungry that day.
After being thrown to the beast
they might be turned loose
later,
or they might be imprisoned for
awhile,
or they might have a different
governor who comes along and
decides to pardon people or
release them.
What do you do with people who
are condemned to martyrdom but
not actually martyred?
Well, they were very close to
martyrdom so that makes them
very close to God.
Remember, if martyrs,
right after they die go to
heaven to be with Christ,
they're right there in heaven,
and therefore you can kind of
pray to martyrs to intercede
with God or Christ for you
because they're in heaven
already.
This idea that martyrs could be
intercessors for living
Christians develops.
This even carries over to where
if you are condemned to
martyrdom but you don't actually
get martyred,
you become what they call a
confessor.
This is because people can
confess to you,
they can confide in you,
they can help you.
So even people who are not
actually martyred that have been
condemned to death at some point
for their faith,
they attained a certain kind of
closeness to God through that
activity,
and they gained therefore a
certain kind of authority.
Now this was not an official
ecclesiastical authority.
No institution of the church
granted these confessors their
authority,
but they developed this
authority because people
respected them and trusted them.
Confessors became somewhat of
like charismatic authority
figures in the early church.
Now this caused problems in a
few places.
Because what if you have a
bunch of people going out to see
some monk who's now a confessor
because he was condemned to
martyrdom but then still lived,
and they're asking his opinions
about,
should I eat meat on Friday?
What days of the week should I
pray on?
Is it okay to do this?
Is it okay to do that?
What if the confessor gives a
different answer from the
bishop?
Well some people might think
the confessor,
who is closer to God after all,
has more authority even than
the bishop.
Well, bishops don't like this
of course,
they consider themselves the
authority in that location,
and so you get sometimes
problems of who's the greater
authority?
The confessor,
the martyr type figure,
or the ecclesiastical official
figure of the bishop?
Notice what Ignatius does with
this, though.
He spends a lot of time in his
letters claiming the authority
of a martyr because he's on his
way to being killed.
He says, don't save me,
I want to be killed as a
martyr.
But Ignatius also is one of the
earliest people we have in
Christianity who claims great
authority also for himself as
bishop.
Now he wouldn't necessarily
have authority as a bishop over
anywhere except the region he
was actually a bishop.
He wasn't the bishop of the
world;
he was the bishop of Antioch,
the town in the east where Paul
and Barnabas spent a good bit of
their time.
His actual official
ecclesiastical authority as
bishop was only in Antioch and
its environs.
He's playing up his martyrology
kind of authority so that he can
exercise a bit of authority even
over these other churches that
he's writing too.
That gives him a little bit of
a reach of authority.
Notice what he does then with
all this bishop stuff,
and here we see the beginnings
of the development of the
Catholic Church structure at
this very early time.
This is early because we think
that Ignatius is writing these
letters around the year 110.
If you have this developing
episcopacy, that's just the
Greek sort of sounding word for
bishop or bishopric or something
like that.
If you have this developing
office of the bishops--then
that's happening at a fairly
early time in Christianity.
Look therefore at the Letter
to the Trallians,
and its right before the
Letter to the Romans,
chapters 2 and 3.
Your obedience to your bishop,
as though he were Jesus Christ
[wow talk about raising the
bishop up]
shows me plainly enough that
yours is no worldly manner of
life but that of Jesus Christ
himself,
who gave his life for us that
faith in his death might save
you from death.
At the same time however,
it is essential that you should
never act independently of the
bishop as evidently you do not.
You must also be no less
submissive to your clergy.
The Greek word here is
literally
"presbyters."
Remember we've already seen
this word come up,
which means "elders"
more literally in Greek.
Now it's starting to be used
for particular kinds of clergy
in the church.
So we see here the bishop,
presbyters, which will come to
be priests, ...
and mind them as apostles of
Jesus Christ,
our hope in whom we shall one
day be found if our lives are
lived in him.
The deacons, too ...
So now we have this other
office.
We've seen these before, right?
We saw presbyters and deacons,
and bishops in a certain sense,
in the Pastoral Epistles,
but they weren't carefully
formed into a three-tiered
institution of offices.
Now we're getting it in
Ignatius.
What will become later basic
church structure,
that lasts up until the
Reformation,
will be bishops on top,
appointed to a particular
location,
so the bishop will be over a
city and all the churches over
this city.
Then under that will be
priests, who have certain
duties,
for example administering the
Eucharist in the mass,
and baptizing,
and under that will be deacons
who have other kinds of duties
in church,
and they're in that 1,2,
3 hierarchy.
The deacons,
too, who serve the mysteries of
Jesus Christ must be men
universally approved in every
way,
since they are not mere
dispensers of meat and drink,
but servants of the church of
God, and therefore under
obligation to guard themselves
against any slur or imputation
as strictly as they would
against the fire itself.
Equally, [this is paragraph 3]
it is for the rest of you to
hold deacons in as great respect
as Jesus Christ,
just as you should look upon
the bishop as a type of the
Father,
and the clergy as the apostolic
circle forming his counsel.
Notice what we've got then,
you've got a Trinity,
almost, of offices that are
matched by something like a
trinity of these figures.
The bishop, is the Father,
the deacons are Jesus Christ,
and the presbyters--he calls
them an apostolic council.
What he's doing is he's
actually setting up these
offices of the early church to
look kind of like a law court.
Where you have a judge and you
would have other officials.
So he's imitating Roman
official legal and political
government structures by having
regional bishops presiding over
a plurality of priests who then
are also over a plurality of
deacons.
What makes it really odd is
that he equates Jesus,
the Father, and Apostles with
deacons, bishop,
and clergy.
He's giving these men in these
offices a great deal of power.
In fact, it's giving them way
more power and authority than
most of us historians think they
actually had at this point.
We know from other historical
documents that bishops didn't
have that much power until much
later.
Presbyters didn't have that
much until way later.
So Ignatius is trying to pump
up what is actually a fairly new
structure of authority and
institutional structure in
these.
He says all the time things
like, don't do anything without
the bishop.
He talks about,
in the Letter to the
Magnesians,
paragraph 6,
he talks about "the
bishop's authority is the
authority of God the
Father."
He says in Magnesians
paragraph 7, "
the bishop is to be regarded it
as the Lord Himself."
What is he doing here?
He's writing these to these
different churches,
and even in fact scriptural
interpretation--
the main thing about modern
Protestantism is the idea that
every Christian is responsible
only to the reading of
scripture,
scripture only.
Your responsibility is to find
the will of God through
scripture, though the revelation
of scripture.
Ignatius totally disagrees with
that.
He says there should be no
individual interpretation of
scripture apart from your
bishop.
Why?
Ignatius knows what we've all
learned ourselves,
that you make a text mean
anything you want,
and as we see from
Protestantism,
fracturing up into a million
different denominations in
churches,
all claiming to be following
the Bible,
you can make the Bible say
whatever you want it to say,
and everybody does.
So Ignatius also,
he says, you can't even
interpret scripture on your own.
You have to do that in an
agreement the bishop.
What have we seen here going on?
We see Christianity,
this fledgling movement,
starting to imitate the
structures of the Roman Empire.
It's no longer a bunch of
simply house churches that are
loosely federated by the fact
that they send letters back and
forth,
and have emissaries between
them.
It's no longer an authority
structure where Paul simply has
to exert his authority as much
as he can through his own force
of will and his charismatic
authority,
and claim authority as an
apostle, although he doesn't
have paper.
Nobody ever gave Paul a diploma
that said, "Paul is now an
Apostle."
He couldn't refer to his
Princeton Seminary,
theological seminary diploma to
prove his authority.
He just had to depend on this
claim that he had that he had
seen the risen Jesus,
that he had had this revelation
experience.
We're moving from that kind of
charismatic exercise of
authority to what is now much
more institutional kinds of
hierarchy structure of
authority.
Medieval Christianity would
itself, therefore,
imitate the structures of
monarchy and empire.
Who elects the Pope?
We'll see later that,
in this period,
bishops seem to actually have
been elected by the people,
at least by the presbyters.
In bishops weren't often
elected.
Bishops in the modern Roman
Catholic Church are not elected
by the people,
they're appointed by the
Vatican.
Who elects the Pope?
Well the cardinals.
So if the Pope is elected,
but by only a limited number of
men, old men who themselves were
appointed by previous Popes.
This is not a democratic system
that the Roman Catholic Church
is structured on.
What is it structured on?
It's structured on monarchical
and imperial ideas of politics.
The-- in the ancient world,
in the Middle Ages,
so you have an emperor and you
have a pope and they come to
hold their power in remarkably
similar ways.
They each have a court,
the emperor or the king has a
court of officials with knights
and that sort of thing that
advise him and carry out his
will.
The Pope has a house with
cardinals and bishops.
The Reformation comes along and
things change.
The Reformers,
of course, sort of claim that
what they were doing was simply
getting back to the biblical
model.
That's not really right.
What they were doing was
reflecting what was a rising
bourgeoisie form that was at
least a bit more like Republican
or Democratic political
structures.
Protestant churches have their
different kinds of ways of
structuring themselves,
which are not free from
political influence either,
they just represent the early
modern political structures that
arose as the bourgeoisie in
Europe developed more and more
power and took more powers onto
itself.
The growth of a mercantile
middle class,
and the decline of the
aristocracy in Europe,
led to more Democratic
tendencies, first in towns,
and then in countries overall.
It led to Republicanism.
The Dutch were the first to
completely get rid of kings and
have a modern republic.
And then of course the United
States becomes the most famous
of modern republics in the
beginning.
In place of having the king or
the emperor in control,
you're supposed to have
constitutional controls.
Things that bodies of people
come together to make laws and
constitutions,
and then you use that
constitutional control to bring
about unity.
Now of course,
as we've seen in our own modern
politics,
you can't always depend upon
the constitutions to protect you
from certain rulers,
but that's the ideal reflecting
a modern movement.
That's one of the ways that you
see how Christianity both comes
out in the ancient world,
changes in the medieval period
and then changes again in the
early modern period.
It's reflecting the changes
that are going on also in
politics in society,
which we of course shouldn't be
surprised about.
The other thing that we can see
developing too is,
and we see this more from the
Didache,
the other document I asked you
to read today,
the shift toward trying to
control things like liturgy.
The Didache is simply a
Greek work meaning "the
teaching,"
because this document purports
to be the teaching of the twelve
apostles.
Now it wasn't actually written
by the twelve apostles.
It was written much later.
It may have been written around
the same time as the letters of
Ignatius.
Most people place it around the
turn of the first century,
so around the year 100 or a
little bit after that.
It's called,
The Teaching of the Twelve
Apostles,
and it's the first time we get
in Christian literature
something like a manual on how
to do it.
Here's how you're supposed to
do worship service,
here's how you're supposed to
do a baptism,
do the Eucharist to the mass.
Here's what authority
structures you have.
It was discovered in 1873,
so really it's a very modern
discovery, didn't exist from the
ancient period.
As far as we know,
it was discovered in a
monastery in Istanbul,
Constantinople that is,
now Istanbul.
The importance of the discovery
of this document is hard to
overestimate because it's just a
great,
great document for seeing how
early Christians actually
practiced their liturgy.
It's very dependent upon the
Gospel of Matthew and the letter
of James in the New Testament.
It shows a lot of things like
that, it's also dependent upon
certain Greek philosophical and
Hellenistic Jewish ideas.
Now let's just look at some of
the things it says.
Look on chapter 7 of the
Didache.
We get hints about how early
Christians did baptisms from
different places.
We think most of the time that
baptism,
in the earliest period,
was not sprinkling the water or
dipping a little water on
somebody,
but putting people all the way
under the water.
We also get hints maybe that
they had people do it at night,
and they had people do it
naked.
So you took off your clothes,
you went down into the water,
you were baptized,
you came up,
and they put a white robe or
something else on you.
We have a few hints about this,
but this is the earliest
docuemnt we have with anything
like these instructions.
It says now about baptism:
"This is how to baptize.
Give public instruction on all
these points,
and then baptize in running
water...."
Notice, it actually says
"living water"
in the Greek,
but what it means is,
try to baptize in a river or
something that has actual
running water and not in still
water,
if you can....
in the name of the Father,
and of the Son,
and the Holy Spirit.
[so you have Trinitarian
formula as part of the baptism]
If you do not have running
water, baptize in some other.
If you cannot in cold,
then in warm [so they had to be
baptized in cold water].
Before the baptism moreover,
the one who baptizes and the
one being baptized must fast,
[so you have fasting ahead of
time]
and any others who can,
and you must tell the one being
baptized to fast for one or two
beforehand.
Then he goes into fasting,
here's how you're supposed to
fast:
Your fast must not be identical
with those of the hypocrites.
They fast on Mondays and
Thursdays but he should fast on
Wednesdays and Fridays.
Who are the hypocrites?
Probably Jews.
He's probably trying to say,
I don't want you Christians to
fast in the same fast days of
the weeks that Jews are fasting
on,
so he gives them other days to
fast.
Notice what he says:
he gives the Lord's Prayer,
which is familiar to most
modern people.
Our Father in heaven,
hallowed by your name.
Your kingdom come,
you will be done on Earth as it
is in heaven.
Give us today our bread for the
tomorrow.
Forgive us our debts as we
forgive our debtors.
Do not lead us into temptation
but save us from the evil one,
for yours is the power and the
glory forever.
That sounds a lot like the
Lord's Prayer that you yourself
may often say in church if you
ever go to church.
If you notice carefully,
this prayer is actually
more like what most
modern Christians pray in church
than is either the version of
the Lord's Prayer in Matthew or
Luke.
In other words,
he's closer to what we actually
pray today than either the
prayer version in Matthew or
Luke,
which is a very interesting
fact in itself,
that our prayer comes more from
a tradition,
it's closer to the
Didache,
than it is to the Bible.
Notice that he gives them
instructions on the Eucharist.
One of the interesting things
is if you go to a church
nowadays, usually what they do
is, they bless the bread first
and then the cup of wine.
He actually has it the other
way around.
He says, you give the cup first
and then the bread.
You have, first,
prayers of thanksgiving,
and it's this word thanksgiving
that we actually get the term
"Eucharist,"
and that just comes from the
Greek word
"thanksgiving."
If you go to different
Christian denominations,
they'll call this differently.
Some places call it the Lord's
Supper,
some people call it just the
Communion,
and if you--some churches,
especially Episcopal churches,
will call it the Eucharist.
Catholic Churches,
they usually call it the Mass,
but they're all referring
basically to the same thing,
the sharing of the bread and
the wine.
He gives instructions on that.
Notice it says the Eucharist is
to be restricted to only
baptized Christians.
You don't give the bread and
win to people who are not
baptized.
Then he gives some prescribed
prayers in chapter 10,
and it's interesting.
Now we're not in a time where
people are just allowed to pray
any old way they want too,
he actually gives written
prayers that he wants them to
use.
Again, don't exaggerate this
guy's control,
whoever's writing this.
We don't believe that this
document was actually
controlling behavior of all
Christians of this time.
He's trying to bring about some
unity and conformity in a time
when, we historians assume,
there was a still a huge amount
of diversity.
By publishing this document and
telling people even how to pray
he's trying to bring about this
kind of unity.
In chapter 14,
it's interesting because he's
give the different events that
would take place on the Lord's
Day, that is Sunday.
For example,
you're supposed to have
confession,
you confess your sins,
you're supposed to reconcile
with anybody that you're not in
agreement with,
and then you have the
Eucharist, which he talks about
as a sacrifice.
Paul had never talked about
sort of The Lord's Supper as
being something alike a
sacrifice.
In later Christianity it will
be considered something like a
sacrifice,
and so that's why you can only
have a priest do it because it
actually changes the elements
and something real is going on
there.
The Eucharist has by this time
started becoming considered
something like a sacrifice for
Christians who don't have any
other form of sacrifice,
because Christians don't go
around sacrificing lambs or
anything else.
Then you have different
leaders, he has in chapter 11
roles for apostles,
and he also has roles for
prophets.
Notice what he said in chapter
11, and I think is really
interesting.
This is a time when there seems
to be regular sorts of officers,
but then there are these
non-sort of regular officers.
Now about the apostles and
prophets, act in line with the
gospel precept.
Welcome every apostle on
arriving as if he were the Lord.
But he must not stay beyond one
day;
in case of necessity,
however, the next day too.
If he stays three days he is a
false prophet.
On departing,
an apostle must not accept
anything, save sufficient food
to carry him until his next
lodging.
If he asks for money he is a
false prophet.
So he's kind of mixing these
words--apostle and prophet.
Remember "apostle"
just means "one who is
sent out"
in Greek.
What he's talking about are
roving prophets who go around to
different churches.
And it's really interesting.
He says, let him stay with you
two or three days.
If he's going to stay longer
than that he's going to have to
start working for his bread.
And if you have a prophet who
says, I'm getting a message,
I'm getting a message,
oh yeah you're supposed to give
me $5, Jesus says so.
Then you know he's a false
prophet and you kick him out.
It's a nice way to figure out
which are genuine prophets and
which are false prophets.
If this were followed in most
modern Christianity,
it would have a lot of false
prophets not on TV.
Unfortunately it doesn't work
in modern Christianity,
so we have a lot of false
prophets on TV asking for a lot
of money.
There's also in chapter 12,
this is not just true for
prophets.
He talks about how to treat
other travelers.
The churches are becoming
something almost like hotels,
which makes sense,
because in the ancient world
there aren't really very many
hotels.
You couldn't just check in at
the Motel 6 or the Holiday Inn,
when you're traveling around.
You have to stay with friends.
There are a few taverns,
yes, some brothels,
but they're not very safe.
In fact they're very unsafe,
and they're not respectable
places for a good person to
stay.
They're houses of ill repute.
And so what do you do if you're
good respectable Christian and
you want all your other fellow
Christians to know that you
haven't been sleeping around
when you're on your business
trip?
Well, you have to either stay
with friends or,
now increasingly,
you can stay with the church.
But, he says,
if you have these travelers who
come in and they want to stay
more than two or three days,
then they have to get a job,
and they have to start
supporting themselves.
You see him developing this
church as a networked
organization.
Again, we have more and more
organization coming into play
here,
that has defined offices and
some others that aren't so well
defined,
like these traveling prophets
which he's trying to regularize.
He's trying to give rules for
an institution of the prophet,
because that itself is not an
institutional kind of office in
early Christianity.
So, with Ignatius and with the
Didache,
we have moved a long way from
this tiny little band of
followers of a Jewish
apocalyptic prophet named Jesus
of Nazareth.
In fact, we've even moved a
good ways away from the informal
charismatic kind of house
churches planted by the apostle
Paul.
We're now seeing the
institution.
We've not yet arrived at what
will become Christianity.
That is, with all the trappings
of late antiquity,
full church structures,
creeds, doctrines,
social networks,
monasticism,
this will be a big thing that
starts developing especially in
the third,
fourth, and fifth centuries,
the rise of monasticism as
another form of Christianity
that provides a very important
structure for it that will last
all the way through the medieval
period.
We don't have that yet.
We don't have a Canon yet.
We don't have a Canon even of
the Old Testament,
much less of the New Testament
yet.
We see developing in the
letters of Ignatius and in the
Didache the beginnings of
this later development and to
what will become a more mature
Christianity.
The move from that late antique
Christianity though,
say, to the Christianity of the
fourth century when we get the
major creeds,
like the Nicene Creed,
and the Creed of Chalcedon,
to modern Christianity,
and it being what we call a
"world religion,"
is itself centuries away
though.
I'll talk about that next time.
What we've done this whole
semester is barely scratch the
surface of what would be the
history of Christianity.
The main point of the
scratching has been to get you
to see that,
at the very beginning,
the first one hundred years of
this Christian movement--
because that's basically all
we've covered,
and not all that either,
but the basic first one hundred
years--
this was not anything like the
religion it came to be.
It was diverse,
it was widely different across
geographic areas,
it had lots of different
doctrines.
There wasn't anything called
orthodoxy yet and heresy yet.
That all develops later.
This is the very beginnings of
it.
Any questions,
comments, or outbursts?
Okay I'll see you next time.
We will also hand out the final
paper instructions next time in
class.